la relance de 2007-2008 a pris le pas
sur les autres facteurs de croissance
que la chine soit la première à repartir
c'est une certitude
c'est les premiers à avoir maîtrisé la
pandémie ils ont préféré mettre le
paquet sur la règle du virus et ont
retrouvé des conditions normales
d'activité économique plutôt que sur les
relances monétaire ou de l'endettement
dépasse l'espèce de jeu pouvoir pour la
suprématie mondiale la chine à quelques
mètres d'avancé sur ses poursuivants
[Musique]
la journée des forces armées se solde
par la mort d'au moins 24 heures
protestataires en birmanie ils ont été
tuées dans la répression de nouvelles
manifestations
les militants art et appeler à la
mobilisation en cette date symbolique
jour comme tous les ans du défilé
militaire devant le chef de l'armée
désormais chef de la junte au pouvoir
[Musique]
contrôle renforcé en france aux
aéroports et aux péages routiers ch pour
faire respecter l'interdiction se
déplacer dix-neuf départements au total
sont aujourd'hui soumis aux mesures de
restriction sur tout le territoire la
situation épidémique et critique les
hôpitaux sont tous tension près de 3
millions de doses de vaccin anti colis
devraient être livrés la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]
la france portent des responsabilités
lourdes et accable on entre dans le
génocide des tutsi au rwanda
les conclusions du rapport d'historiens
publié hier était très attendu ils
dénoncent l'aveuglément du président de
l'époque montrent indifférents et son
entourage
ce rapport marque une avancée
considérable pour comprendre
l'engagement français au rwanda estime à
emmanuel magne
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france l'onu déplore
des dizaines de morts dont des enfants
dans la répression des manifestants bien
manie grande bretagne etats unis union
européenne
les réactions se multiplient après ces
violences qui ont émaillé cette nouvelle
journée de mobilisation à travers le
pays
mobilisation contre la junte militaire
au pouvoir depuis le coup d'état du 1er
février des morts aujourd'hui mais aussi
des centaines de blessés dans 40
localités et des arrestations massives
lors de la journée des forces armées de
birmanie
les forces de sécurité assassinent des
civils non armés y compris des enfants
les mêmes personnes qu'elles ont juré de
protéger cette effusion de sang est
horrible
ce ne sont pas les actions d'une force
militaire ou de police à l'occasion de
la journée des forces armées de birmanie
les forces de sécurité se sont
déshonorés en tirant sur des civils non
armés
en cette période de crise économique qu
vide et une situation humanitaire qui
s'aggrave aujourd'hui le défilé
militaire et les exécutions
extrajudiciaires en disent long sur les
priorités de la junte militaire cette
76ème journée des forces armée birmane
restera gravée comme une journée de
terreur et de déshonneur le meurtre de
civils non armés y compris d'enfants est
un acte indéfendable l'union européenne
soutient le peuple de birmanie et
appelle à la fin immédiate de la
violence et au rétablissement de la
démocratie est l'une des journées les
plus sanglantes en birmanie en cette
date symbolique donc qui célébrait comme
chaque année ses forces armées
le récit de contes en moncler chars
hélicoptères missiles ou encore des
milliers de soldats
ce samedi la junte birmane au pouvoir a
profité de la journée des forces armées
pour faire étalage de sa force et
répondre aux manifestants soutenant et
en dessous si les militaires au pouvoir
bomber le torse sorte les muscles et
promettent des élections une fois les
mesures de l'état d'urgence levé l'armée
birmane assume
inévitablement la responsabilité de
l'état par des moyens légaux
en raison des actes illégaux du
gouvernement dit
j'ai par la ligue nationale pour la
démocratie lors des élections de 2020
une fois les dispositions de l'état
d'urgence levé des élections libres et
équitables seront organisés et le
transfert de la responsabilité de l'état
se poursuivra la démocratie que nous
appelons de nos voeux deviendrait une
démocratie indisciplinés
si la loi a été violée n'étaient pas
respectées pour rappel l'état d'urgence
a été instauré après l'arrestation et le
renversement de la chef du gouvernement
de facto en dessous si le 1er février
dernier
l'état d'urgence est alors décrété pour
un an en réponse à ce coup d'état
des milliers de birmans descendent dans
les rues du pays pour manifester contre
le pouvoir militaire
le mouvement de contestation est
durement réprimée par la junte
selon un groupe de prisonniers
politiques 320 personnes ont trouvé la
mort depuis le début des manifestations
ce vendredi
l'armée a prévenu qu'elle n'hésiterait
pas à tirer à balles réelles lors des
prochains rassemblements contre la junte
retenez la leçon de ceux qui sont morts
brutalement du danger d'être frappé à
l'arrière de la tête ou dans le dos ne
mourrai pas pour rien malgré ces menaces
des milliers de birmans battent le pavé
aux quatre coins du pays à dahouët dans
le sud
c'est avec une bougie à la main que les
opposants ont marché à travers la ville
avant le lever du soleil un peu plus
tard dans la journée des affrontements
ont eu lieu lors de rassemblements à
rangoon à la chaux ou encore à die ku
nous ne devons pas laisser ces généraux
autorisé des célébrations après avoir
tué nos frères et soeurs
ils sont l'ennemi de la démocratie nous
ne nous rendrons jamais tant que la
liberté ne sera pas acquise pour notre
peuple
plusieurs morts et blessés sont d'ores
et déjà à déplorer ce samedi pourrait
être la journée la plus meurtrière
depuis le début de la répression des
manifestations
en france déjà en vigueur dans seize
départements les nouvelles la mesure de
restriction s'applique désormais rhône à
l'aube et à la nièvre commerces à fermer
demi classe en lycée et pas de
déplacement à plus de dix kilomètres
sans dérogation les contrôles aux
aéroports et péages routiers ont ainsi
été renforcés
matignon a prévenu une course contre la
montre est engagée face à la situation
épidémique critiques sur l'ensemble du
territoire le nombre de malades en
réanimation est en hausse régulière
depuis début janvier 4791 ce samedi
contre 4766 hier les variants mieux
coronavirus accentue la pression sur les
hôpitaux certains établissements sont au
bord de la saturation
il y a deux semaines le gouvernement
lançait pourtant l'opération chardon des
centaines de patients devaient être
transférés des régions où les hôpitaux
sont saturés vers d'autres régions
mais en dix jours seuls 38 malades ont
été évacuées dont seulement 13 depuis
l'île de france
les services médicaux se heurtent
notamment au refus des familles de voir
leurs proches transférer loin de
l'explication des stèles farges devant
l'hôpital parisien georges pompidou 38
en dix jours c'est le nombre de malades
du coït 19 transférés dans des hôpitaux
d'occitanie de bretagne ou encore de
nouvelles aquitaine entre le 13 et le 23
mars selon le ministère de la santé
parmi ces 38 patients 13 sont issus de
l'île de france 12 de la région paca et
9 des hôtes france ce dispositif qui
permet de transférer des patients
attendu qu'ovide 19 des hôpitaux engorgé
par l'afflux de malades vers d'autres un
peu moins sollicités à un nom
l'opération chardon elle a été mise en
place l'année dernière lors de la
première vague de l'épidémie de
coronavirus et avait permis le transfert
de 658 patients en réactivant ce
dispositif à la mi mars le gouvernement
espérait pouvoir déplacer une centaine
de patients depuis l'île de france en
une semaine
mais c'était sans compter sur les
difficultés auxquelles se heurte le
dispositif contrairement à la première
opération chardon de mars 2020 l'accord
des familles pour transférer un patient
est cette fois si nécessaire et les
services hospitaliers font face à de
nombreux refus
le plus difficile c'est la corde et
fanny
sur les cinq patients que nous pouvions
transféré nous n'avons eu qu'un seul
accord c'est vraiment très difficile de
demander aux familles qui ont proche
entre la vie et la mort en réanimation
de l'envoyer à 500 km pour eux c'est
impossible d'accepter ça et on les
comprend outre le refus des familles le
déplacement du patient est aussi
conditionnée par son état de santé il
doit être suffisamment stable pour
permettre un transfert sanitaire ces
patients éligibles représente à peine
plus de 10% des malades actuellement
hospitalisé en réanimation selon le
directeur général de l'ap-hp de critères
qu il est donc difficile de réunir nous
sommes dans l'impossibilité à la fois de
trouver des patients éligibles
c'est à dire dans un état relativement
stable afin de respecter les conditions
de sécurité de ce transport et dont les
familles acceptent d'évacuation vers une
autre région
conséquence faute d'un nombre de
patients suffisant le tgv médicalisé
prévue le 18 mars dernier a été annulée
s'il devait notamment permettre de
transférer des patients en provenance
d'île de france selon le ministère de la
santé plus de 1400 malades du coït 19
sont actuellement en réanimation en
ile-de-france et le taux d'incidence lui
frôle les 600 cas pour 100000 habitants
une situation jugée préoccupante mais
pour l'heure le transfert massif de
patients ne semble plus d'actualité et
les espoirs de sortie de crise repose
aujourd'hui sur la vaccination depuis ce
matin elle est accessible aux plus de 70
ans qui ne présente pas de comorbidité
cela représente près de trois millions
et demi de français ils peuvent se faire
injecter le sérum chez leur médecin ou
en pharmacie ou bien encore dans un
centre dédié après une prise de
rendez-vous être d effet d'annonce
déplore pascal soreil les médecins
généralistes en saône et loire
c'est sûr que l'ouverture de la
vaccination plus grand nombre est très
intéressant c'est le plus important
le seul souci c'est que l'on nous donne
pas les moyens c'est à dire qu'on a eu
des annonces de la part du président
comme quoi il fallait vacciner le jour
la nuit les week-ends
le problème c'est que nous avons aucune
dose
mais commandes de vaccins de lundi 22
mars ne seront honorés que le 5 ou le 6
avril et j'aurais que dix doses
dans ces conditions on peut pas vacciner
les gens c'est un effet d'annoncé total
pour moi il ya des mots des mots il ya
aucun acte derrière il ya que des effets
d'annoncé
on va voir on va faire il faut mais sur
le terrain on est totalement démunis et
la ministre délégué à l'industrie chan
espagne et relâché promet l'arrivée de
près de 3 millions de doses de vaccins
la semaine prochaine une stratégie
vaccinale à l'échelle européenne
emmanuel macron là encore défendu hier
en marge d'un conseil européen virtuel
le chef de l'état qui voit dans l'accès
au sérum anti copie d'une guerre
mondiale dans dawn ou d'un nouveau genre
taclant au passage pékin et moscou david
khalifa ce n'est pas une décision
politique mais une décision scientifique
heureusement un discours qui a bien
changé en l'espace d'un mois et demi
pour soutenir et emmanuel macron
considère maintenant le vaccin russe
comme une arme d' influence faut être
très clair nous sommes face à une guerre
mondiale d'un nouveau genre
face notamment aux attaques aux
velléités de déstabilisation russe
chinoise d' influence par le vaccin
face à cela si nous voulons tenir nous
devons être souverain nous nous sommes
mis aujourd'hui en capacité de produire
pour ce faire nos retards nos
manquements au tout début je considère
que nous avons rattrapé les choses et
que nous sommes en train de répondre à
cette crise des mots qui sont bien loin
de la réalité concernant cette campagne
de vaccination qui piétinent en france
et pourtant d'un point de vue purement
scientifique puisque en aucun cas la
décision n'est politique des solutions
existent spoutnik v répond parfaitement
aux exigences d'un vaccin efficace
contre le coc u19 la très sérieuse revue
médicale britannique elle zélande 7
affirme début février qu'il est efficace
à 91,6 % surpassant de loin le vaccin
astrazeneca efficace à 76% et donc dans
la même cour que les moderna et autres
par heather greentech eux mêmes sur à
plus de 90% le développement du vaccin
foot nivet a été critiqué pour sa
précipitation
le fait qu'il ait brûler des étapes et
une absence de transparence mais les
résultats rapportés ici sont claires et
le principe scientifique de cette
vaccination est démontrée cela veut dire
qu'un vaccin supplémentaire peut
désormais rejoindre le combat pour
réduire l'incidence du coc vie de 19
compte tenu de l'urgence sanitaire et de
la lenteur de la campagne de vaccination
en europe des questions peuvent se poser
au vu de ces conclusions
une demande d'homologation est certes
actuellement examiné par l' agence
européenne des médicaments mais en
parallèle une véritable bataille
géopolitique se dessine
jean yves le drian n'hésite pas à
employer les grands mots et considère
que le vaccin tout nick v est utilisé
comme un outil de propagande à la
manière dont ces gérer c'est plus un
moyen de propagande et de diplomatie
agressive quand moyen de solidarité et
dead sanitaires on pourrait presque
employer le terme déstabilisation si
chère à emmanuel macron en ce moment
quoi qu'il en soit si on s'attache à
refaire la chronologie du vaccin
spoutnik v la france tient un triple
discours pour le moins troublant d'abord
sceptique puis intéressé finalement
accusateur les développeurs du spoutnik
v ont d'ailleurs répondu à cette attaque
invitant le président français a laissé
la question des vaccins hors de la
sphère politique tout en soulignant
l'importance de la coopération cher
emmanuel macron rendre les vaccins à
politique est notre meilleur espoir de
paix mondiale et non de guerre
nous vous sommes reconnaissants d'avoir
envoyé une équipe scientifique française
sous la direction de marie paule kieny
et notre partenariat avec la france nous
a beaucoup aidés et contribuer à notre
combat commun contre le coc vide
oui la france a bel et bien envoyé
délégation scientifique à moscou fin
novembre pour discuter de la production
du vaccin russe une information
pratiquement passée inaperçue et
pourtant ô combien importante
aujourd'hui puisque ce voyage a été
approuvé par emmanuel m'apprend 8 mai et
les conclusions de ce déplacement faite
par la chef de la délégation parler des
nerfs le vaccin spoutnik v vaut la peine
d'être considérées dans la course
internationale
sa technologie repose comme pour les
vaccin développé par astrazeneca pfizer
par exemple sur deux vecteurs viraux
les données détaillées que nous avons
consultés semble correspondre aux
chiffres avancés dans les communiqués de
presse qu
était jusqu'à présent notre seule source
des déclarations qui concordent avec
celles de la revue lancet
rappelons également que spoutnik et à
d'ores et déjà été enregistrées dans
plus de 50 pays
la sphère géopolitique prend le dessus
sur l'aspect sanitaire et c'était là
souvenons nous tout le danger qu'il
fallait éviter la troisième vague
déferle partout en europe c'est le cas
de la pologne confronté en hausse record
des contaminations
conséquence les restrictions se
durcissent le gouvernement a annoncé la
fermeture de nouveaux magasins ainsi que
des crèches et des écoles maternelles
une décision mal comprise par une partie
de la population qui continue de
travailler jeudi n'a d'autres liens
j'ai une famille à faire vivre j'ai un
enfant un chien des crédits si la police
vient qu'est-ce que j'y peux
je garde juste ma famille en vie ce
n'est pas un jeu je ne joue pas c'est
mon travail
est-ce que j'en ferais la loi
probablement pas je ne le prends pas
comme ça je pense que la loi est violée
parce qu'ils sont tout en haut
je suis inquiet de travailler de vivre
dans un tel pays
tout le monde dans notre pays peut être
inquiet d'être nés ici alors qu'il y ait
une pandémie ou pas cela n'a pas
d'importance
ce qui compte c'est que cet état est
inefficace corrompus c'est ça le plus
gros problème
une stratégie vaccinale visiblement
efficaces ont servi chacun des pays en
tête de la vaccination
depuis hier et jusqu'à demain les
citoyens étrangers peuvent se faire
vacciner gratuitement et sans prise de
rendez vous n'est que la petit
géographiquement située au coeur du
vieux continent
la serbie semble bien loin des échecs de
ses voisins de l'union européenne le
pays a déjà administré une dose à plus
d'un million trois cent mille personnes
soit environ 16 % de sa population
leader européen de la vaccination est la
serbie a été l'une des pionnières dans
l'utilisation du spoutnik vais d'ici le
mois de mai elle sera aussi la première
nation du sud du continent à produire le
sérum russe grâce à l'accord conclu
entre l'institut tornade de virologie et
le fonds souverains russes
l'organe chargé de son développement à
l'étranger la serbie deviendra le
premier état d'europe du sud qui
produira le spoutnik v dont l'avenir
elle pourrait l'exporter vers d'autres
pays de la région la production du
spoutnik v par l'institut orlhac
simplifiera la logistique et accélérera
la mise en oeuvre du programme de
vaccination en serbie
en plus du spoutnik v la serbie a
également signé un accord avec la chine
pour produire le vaccin sinopharm mais
la serbie ne s'arrête pas là depuis ce
vendredi le pays a encore franchi un cap
avec l'ouverture de sa vaccination aux
ressortissants étrangers et c'est un
succès une véritable ruée a eu lieu vers
ses principaux centres de vaccination
comme ici dans la capitale
nous avons décidé de venir en serbie cas
en bosnie la vaccination n'a pas encore
commencé c'est génial c'est très bien
organisé
excellent même j'ai reçu une invitation
de la chambre de commerce monténégrin et
serbes
en tant qu'homme d'affaires et j'ai
décidé de venir ici car j'ai besoin de
voyager pour mon travail
il est plus facile de voyager quand on
est vaccinés tout le monde devrait
saisir cette chance pour se faire
vacciner et terminer sa vaccination
de cette façon le monde pourra plus
rapidement revenir à la normale en tout
ce sont dix mille doses de vaccins qui
ont été mises à disposition par les
autorités pour vacciner citoyens
étrangers migrants présents sur son
territoire
la serbie se montre particulièrement
généreuse et a également décidé de
donner des sérums à ses voisins
permettant à certains d'entre eux de
lancer leur campagne de vaccination
comme la macédoine du nord
le monténégro et la bosnie-herzégovine
la france a failli au rwanda elles
portent des responsabilités accablante
dans le génocide des tutsi selon un
rapport d'historiens remis hier à
emmanuel macron pointé du doigt le
président de l'époque françois
mitterrand et son entourage aveugle et
idéologiquement selon les termes
employés
les détails avec solène gaudin une étude
remise en main propre à emmanuel macron
le rapport du clair une avancée
considérable selon le chef de l'état il
aura fallu deux ans de recherches dans
les archives pour établir ce bilan de
plus de 1000 pages sur un sujet explosif
l'implication militaire et politique de
la france dans le génocide des tutsi au
rwanda en 1994
entre 1990 et 1994 le rwanda plonge dans
un conflit politique et ethnique
la france s'engage militairement dans le
pays officiellement pour protéger les
expatriés étrangers mais la présence de
l'armée française s'avère defacto
dissuasive face à l'offensive rebelle
malgré les nombreuses alertes mettant en
garde contre les dérives génocidaire du
gouvernement rwandais
françois mitterrand alors président de
la france s'aligne sur kigali
d'abord pensé à mes parents avaient des
liens très étroits avec le président
habyarimana et habyarimana on jouait
énormément pour obtenir toute la france
sans rien concéder c'est à dire que par
exemple il y a des cartes d'identités
ethniques qui ont servi ensuite lors du
génocide à éliminer les tutsis et bien
la france aurait pu faire pression
refusé de donner des moyens militaires
tank habyarimana n'aurait pas modifié
les cartes d'identité entre avril et
juillet 1994 au moins huit cent mille
personnes majoritairement outils sont
exterminés dans des conditions
abominables
si le rapport duclair établi sans
concession l'aveuglément idéologique et
la faillite de l'exécutif français de
l'époque sur ce dossier en revanche il
écarte la complicité de génocide
longtemps dénoncés par le rwanda pour
nous chercheurs historiens dans la
commission la combinaison jaune au site
c'est de cet associé intentionnellement
à l'entreprise génocidaire ils nous
seront constatés ce très important de
l'aider
c'est que dans toutes les archives ya
aucun document qui montrent que la
france voulait s'associer à cette
entreprise génocidaire
après le génocide puis la victoire des
rebelles du front patriotique rwandais
les responsables politiques français
avait soutenu avoir sauvé l'honneur de
la communauté internationale en étant
les seuls à intervenir dans le pays avec
l'opération turquoise dont la légitimité
et les intentions sont également très
critiqué depuis juillet 1994
la france est le rwanda entretenait des
relations tendues après la publication
de ce rapport
l'elysée a appelé à un rapprochement
irréversible avec kigali
de son côté le rwanda s'est félicitée de
la publication de ce rapport est dit y
voir un pas vers une compréhension
commune du rôle de la france dans ce
génocide et les associations de victimes
du génocide réclamait la justice ainsi
qu'une prise de position de la part du
gouvernement écouter l'état français a
été complice de génocide en 1994
et si ce rapport ne le dit pas nous
attendons de l'exécutif une prise de
parole forte pour que cette complicité
soit reconnue c'est le seul moyen pour
qu'il y ait ensuite un contrôle
démocratique qui se mit en place sur nos
institutions sur les opérations
extérieures
le risque sinon c'est que ce type
d'actions soit répétée et qu'elle se
répéter au nom du peuple français
ça change beaucoup parce que il ya
énormément de négationnisme notamment en
france je fais de la présence de génos
sévère et de leur famille sur le
territoire
donc le fait que les politiques prennent
enfin en compte ces mots la force ça ne
peut être qu'une bonne chose parce que
ça permet aussi un petit peu de faire
reculer le sentiment d'impunité
ces mots là c'est très bien mais il ya
des personnes à juger en france il ya
des personnes dont il faut regarder
quelles furent leurs actes leurs mots
leurs écrits lors du génocide et ça n'a
pu être en fait les actes notre
préoccupation au jour le jour
il était en discussion depuis plusieurs
années l'iran et la chine signent un
accord de coopération stratégique et
commercial de vos mains qu'on s'est
grandi n'ont toutefois pas encore été
dévoilé la chine est le premier
partenaire commercial de la république
islamique pour pékin cet accord
s'inscrit dans son vaste projet des
nouvelles routes de la soie lancé avec
plus de 130 pays
l'éclairage de gérard vespière et les
fondateurs du web magazine le monde
décrypté contenu il est économique il
est dans le domaine des transports et
dans le domaine des facilités portuaires
ou peut-être même dans l'acquisition
d'un port puisque là bien sûr il y à
toutes les architectures des routes de
la soie chinoise a des nouvelles routes
de la soie vert vers l'europe
donc voilà la l'iran était effectivement
un et la chine sont des partenaires
économiques fort à l'iran a fourni
beaucoup de pétrole à la chine pendant
de nombreuses années beaucoup moins
maintenant et il ya depuis quelques
années une diminution paradoxalement de
leur commerce réciproque puisque les
échanges sont tombés d'un tiers depuis
2018 donc voyez vous tout n'est pas
forcément rose
un retour en france mobilisation ce
samedi contre le mal logement schl
mobilisation notamment à paris à l'appel
du collectif prenons la ville plusieurs
dizaines de personnes se sont
rassemblées place du châtelet pour
dénoncer l'inflation du prix des loyers
et la hausse du nombre des expulsions
parmi les revendications une baisse
immédiate des loyers ou encore une
taxation des plus values liées à la
spéculation
compte rendu de la manifestation
parisienne avec notre reporter mohamud
est là ils ont été plusieurs centaines à
répondre à l'appel du collectif prônons
la vie pour défendre le droit au
logement et protester contre les
expulsions
et les logements chers en appelle à la
mobilisation qui a été lancé dans tout
le pays
mais cette mobilisation ici à paris à la
députée place du châtelet aux alentours
de 15 heures parmi sept parmi ce cortège
plusieurs associations de plusieurs
syndicats également venu soutenir cette
cause du logement je vais me propose
d'écouter les témoignages de personnes à
qui nous avons pu parler d'eux d'entre
elles subissent la précarité vos
logements écouter le message il faut
traiter les femmes et sans papiers comme
des êtres humains parce que les laissant
papy ce sens ce sont des êtres humains
surtout les enfants là bas pour les
enfants alors pour cette période de
crise il faut penser rousse offert aux
familles sans papiers quand vous pensez
à autre fin du mois moi ça fait quatre
ans que je suis là je dis que je suis un
être humain quand vous on vient tous de
la même planète
et franchement on vivre on peut en veut
on veut vivre dignement nous sommes là
aujourd'hui nous soutenons le droit au
logement parce que c'est un droit
fondamental et aujourd'hui effectivement
c'est d'abord la spéculation financière
qui fait que ce droit au logement qui
est un droit fondamental n'est pas
respectée et que aujourd'hui on est en
france dans un pays où il ya 10 millions
de personnes pauvres et parmi ces 10
millions de personnes peau beaucoup sont
dans une situation extrêmement difficile
en terme d'hébergement d'habitation et
notre réaction radicale elle est sur le
terrain et dans les institutions
réclamer un changement des droits sur le
terrain cette dire attention il ya
beaucoup plus de gens expulsables cette
année que jamais avant parce qu'on n'a
jamais vu une telle différence entre les
prix de vente
les loyers et la possibilité de payer
les loyers pendant la période qu'ovide
est donc actuellement il ya pratiquement
toutes les expulsions de l'année
dernière + 7 de cette année le double du
volume de menaces d'expulsions que
d'habitude il y avait plusieurs prises
de parole notamment deux collectifs et
d'associations sans papiers qui alerte
le gouvernement et qui dette qui demande
d'être mise à l'abri le plus rapidement
possible
ce cortège et bien il devait s'arrêter
devant le ministère de l'écologie
puisque l'écologie est un des thèmes
abordés également par tous et collectif
le
au logement aux normes écologiques mais
finalement elle et forces de l'ordre en
ont décidé autrement et la dispersion et
bien elle va se faire sur le boulevard
saint germain
et c'est la fin de cette édition
prochain point sur la cud en une
trentaine de minutes
à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petits échos positifs a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité
les ide et courageuse des mots qui
compte à peine en soi vient de
l'ignorance
aujourd'hui une gauche extrême musée le
matin la société
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]